vous allez quitter ce plateau vous allez
être remplacé laisser bien vos micros
s'il vous plaît sur les tables par les
candidats de la deuxième circonscription
du doubs le temps qui s'installe je vous
présente cette 2e circonscription
c'est en fait l'autre circonscription de
l'agglomération de besançon
besançon est donc avec les communes de
beurre chalezeule mort ou saône jusqu'à
la vallée de la loue et ornans le député
sortant celle écologiste eric alauzet
avant lui l'ump jacques grosperrin la
socialiste paulette guinchard et l'udf
michel jacquemin jacquemin pardon ont
représenté sept circonscriptions à paris
les résultats de la présidentielle il ya
quelques semaines dans cette
circonscription emmanuel macron macron
était en tête du premier tour score
supérieur à 25% son meilleur résultat de
notre région 2e françois fillon 3e jean
luc mélenchon 4e marine le pen c'est
d'ailleurs la seule circonscription de
franche-comté où la présidente du fn ne
figure pas sur le podium au premier tour
bernard bayot de l'est républicain est
toujours en coulisses il va nous
rejoindre dans un instant mais d'abord
david ils sont en place présente et nous
nos invités alors on va commencer avec
eric alauzet c'est le député sortant de
cette 2e circonscription du doubs
bonjour eric alauzet vous êtes avec
l'étiquette cette fois-ci écologistes
divers divers écologistes vous étiez
député écologiste sortant et vous êtes
conseiller municipal de besançon face à
vous on retrouve ludovic fagots bonjour
vous êtes conseiller départemental vice
président du département du doubs et
vous vous présenter avec l'étiquette les
républicains sur ce plateau également et
candidat sur cette 2e circonscription il
y a claire arnoux elle n'a aucun mandat
les la candidate de france insoumise et
c'est sa première candidature sur cette
circonscription également avec nous pour
débattre et candidat sur cette
circonscription du doubs christophe lime
c'est le candidat du pc et du front de
gauche il est adjoint au maire de
besançon
et puis pour boucler la boucle julien
hakkar conseiller municipal et
conseiller régional de bourgogne franche
comté de bourgogne franche comté oui et
vous êtes le candidat du front national
voilà pour les candidats en présence
ils sont aussi candidats sur cette
deuxième circonscription du doubs jean
claude chaumette pour debout la france
josé da cruz candidats divers nadine de
maillots pour le parti animalistes
fabrice delcambre pour lutte ouvrière
alain françois en divers et christine
latournerie pour lui père eric alauzet
vous êtes le député sortant
vous étiez on l'a dit europe ecologie
les verts et vous n'êtes plus bas plus
rien vous n'êtes plus ps vous n'êtes
plus écologiste et vous n'êtes pas en
marche alors vous êtes un candidat sans
étiquette
voilà je suis écologiste c'est ma marque
de fabrique et vous aurez remarqué que
la vie politique est complètement
chamboulé dans cette période et ça fait
longtemps que moi même je suis en
mouvement et en recherche dans cette
période de doute et quelque part entre
les écologistes et socialistes en marche
en tout cas je pars à cette élection
législative avec le soutien d' en marche
l'étiquette majorité présidentielle
alors excusez moi eric alauzet met en
marche ne vous a pas officiellement
investie sur cet instrument
le choix qui a été fait vous vous êtes
placés notamment dans une interview à
l'est républicain sous l'étiquette
majorité présidentielle mais vous n'avez
pas l'investiture officielle et votre
déclaration sous l'étiquette majorité
présidentielle a conduit à la fois le
parti socialiste et europe écologie les
verts a retiré la double investiture que
vous aviez alors finalement on a du mal
à vous suivre
et oui c'est difficile dans la période
puisqu'il ya du doute partout il y en a
qui ont des certitudes qui ne bouge pas
moi je bouge il faut savoir évoluer dans
la période
mon fils c'est l'écologie et puis la
liane dynamique ossements yann ouverture
yab air frais qui souffle sur notre pays
et moi je vais apporter comme le fait
nicolas hulot d'ailleurs ma contribution
à cette majorité présidentielle j'ai le
soutien dans marche
j'ai le soutien du premier secrétaire
fédéral du doubs du parti socialiste non
ce n'est pas rare non c'était pas vrai
eric a déjà envoyé un e-mail à toutes
les rédactions erik à la bonne heure dix
ans on retire l'investiture est parti
socialiste est bien eric alauzet est le
seul capable de remporter cette élection
mais c'était avant que vous vous ralliez
manuellement concernant non pas du tout
il faut regarder les choses précisément
eric alauzet est le seul capable de
remporter cette élection
c'est grâce à son travail et chaque
acharnée qu'il est à même de représenter
notre victoire à votre carnet de note
eric alauzet eric alauzet du fait de son
engagement explicite dans la majorité
présidentielle perd sa double
investiture ps europe ecologie les verts
c'est écrit noir sur blanc au delà des
étiquettes eric alauzet pensez vous que
le libéralisme économique prônée et
revendiquée par emmanuel macron est
compatible avec la défense de
l'environnement je crois qu'il faut
sortir des visions un peu fermé on a
besoin sur nos territoires de liberté
pour entreprendre il faut donner des
marges de manoeuvre à nos jeunes à nos
entrepreneurs aux agriculteurs à tous
les acteurs économiques
il faut leur donner cette liberté
d'entreprendre dans un pays qui est trop
compliqué et en revanche au niveau
international il faut qu'on retrouve
pour contrôler ce libéralisme effréné
il faut qu'on retrouve la fraternité
vous comprenez il faut être aux tensions
en 7 entre le contrôle du libéralisme au
niveau international et le fait de
redonner des libertés sur nos
territoires pour entreprendre
ludovic fargo vous êtes le candidat les
républicains dans cette élection vice
président du département conseiller
municipal d'opposition
vous faites partie de cette nouvelle
génération d'élus à droite à besançon
nous étions candidats aux municipales en
2014 au départemental en 2015 aux
législatives en 2017 vous êtes candidat
à tous n'ont pas forcément candidate ou
en tout cas c'est une continuité dans
laquelle je souhaite personnellement
aussi m'inscrire mais continuité aussi
pour porter des convictions et des
valeurs qui m'ont toujours animé qui
sont celles aussi de ma famille
politique à savoir celle de la droite et
du centre dans lesquels on retrouve bien
sûr les valeurs du travail de la famille
de l'autorité qu'on loi que l'on doit
retrouver et puis de cette liberté
d'entreprendre et de cette laïcité en
refusant le communautarisme et nous
avons bien vu donc dans le cadre de ce
quinquennat dont la majorité sortante et
bien sûr comptable qu'il faut reprendre
un petit peu les choses et retrouver en
tout cas du bon sens et et c'est dans
cette mesure moi que je porte ma
candidature candidats de la droite et du
centre dites-vous la droite et le centre
sont représentés au gouvernement
soutiendrez-vous le gouvernement si vous
êtes élu député
personnellement j'ai des valeurs qui
sont celles de ma famille politique
celle des républicains maintenant je
crois que les gens attendent
effectivement qu'un élu à l'assemblée
nationale de travail en bon sens en bon
sens par rapport aux besoins de la
société par rapport aux besoins et aux
attentes des concitoyens donc
concrètement les deux victoires concrets
comme je ne vois pas pourquoi je ne
participerai pas à des lois la
construction des lois qui vont dans le
bon sens des citoyens parce que je crois
que c'est ce que les gens attendent tout
en gardant et en restant en clarté avec
mes valeurs de droite julien car vous
êtes le candidat du front national
vous vous êtes vous voulez être un
député d'opposition à l'assemblée
bien sûr marine le pen est là la
principale opposition au projet ultra
libérale de monsieur macron nous y
sommes farouchement opposés et nous
souhaitons effectivement être une
opposition majoritaire à cette assemblée
nationale pour pouvoir porter les
paliers valeurs que sont celles des
patriotes à quoi ça sert un député
d'opposition quand on n'a pas de
majorité à l'assemblée alors ben écoutez
déjà l'élection n'a pas encore eu lieu
donc nous verrons si nous avons une
majorité ce que je sus que en quoi je
crois et ce sur quoi je pense que nous
pouvons y prétendre en tant que
finaliste à cette élection
présidentielle et nous déjà nous
pourrons avoir une majorité c'est
évident et en plus nous nous aurons une
opposition tout à fait constructive mais
farouchement opposés
julien car vous êtes conseiller régional
conseiller municipal d'opposition donc
en bourgogne franche-comté à besançon
est même question quelle ludovic fargo
vous êtes candidat à tous
non pas tout puisque d'ailleurs si je
suis élue députée je démissionnerai de
mes mandats locaux
l'objectif oui vous pouvez tout à fait
l'objectif de toute façon c'est évident
c'est d'avoir une continuité politique
là dessus je rejoins monsieur fagots moi
je pense que quand on est candidat
quand on est élu local et bien il est
d'autres de notre responsabilité de
représenter nos électeurs aussi à
d'autres élections par l'homme notamment
parlementaire claire arnaud candidate de
la france insoumise
ça ne vous a pas échappé il ya deux
candidats sur ce plateau qui ont soutenu
lors de la présidentielle la candidature
de jean luc mélenchon christophe lime et
vous le pcf n'a pas présenté de candidat
sur la première circonscription du doubs
l'autre circonscription de besançon
ma question est simple pourquoi n'y at
il pas de traitement réciproque et
pourquoi ne pas vous alliez pour espérer
avoir un député vient donc déjà lié
peut-être deux candidats qui ont fait la
campagne de jean-luc mélenchon pour ma
part j'ai fait la campagne de jean luc
mélenchon pendant la présidentielle en
jouant complètement la présidentielle
donc et il ya surtout un seul candidat
soutenu par jean luc mélenchon est un
seul candidat de la france a soumises
qui ai moi même donc
je porte la candidature de la france à
soumise est de son programme l'avenir en
commun concernant ces histoires de
partage de circonscription je pense
qu'il faut quand même rappeler que les
élections législatives c'est des
élections nationales
donc il s'agit pas de faire des
bisbilles à besançon ou ailleurs il
s'agit de porter un programme au niveau
national la france a soumise est un
mouvement qui investit des candidats
dans toutes les circonscriptions pour
porter ce programme là donc nous on veut
porter ce programme-là ce programme là
et vous n'avez pas de vous allier avec
alors ils partis qui ont soutenu le
candidat à la présidentielle que vous
est-ce que ça ça pose pas problème
donc le parti communiste français a
défini sa stratégie
voilà donc il a décidé de présenter des
candidats dans la moitié des
circonscriptions de france donc ça c'est
des choses que que le parti communiste
doit expliquer la france insoumise un
mouvement ouvert à l'intérieur de la
france a soumise il ya des personnes qui
sont aux membres du parti communiste il
ya des personnes qui sont moins de élevé
il ya des personnes qui sont un ensemble
qui sont membres du parti de gauche
mais il ya surtout beaucoup de personnes
qui ne sont pas encartés et je vais
reprendre vos questions les élections
législatives c'est pour porter un
programme au niveau national nous sommes
les seuls candidats aujourd'hui à
proposer la révocation des élus
nous sommes les seuls candidats à
proposer la sortie du nucléaire il est
seul candidat à le faire dans une
majorité construite donc moi je vois que
vous voulez passer à l'asie donc voila
nous nous sommes là on va laisser
répandre reste un film
nous sommes là pour porter ce
programme-là l'avenir en commun et nous
avons des candidats france insoumise
investit partout
christophe lime vous êtes le candidat
vous pc front de gauche sur le fond vous
êtes plutôt d'accord avec
les candidats de la france insoumise si
vous êtes candidat si vous êtes candidat
pour être député c'est parce que le
culte de la personnalité de jean-luc
mélenchon ne vous convient pas
absolument pas moi je prône l'unité
depuis des mois et des mois mais déjà
sur la présidence je prône l'unité et et
je la fais et je la fais c'est à dire
que quelque part je suis un élu qui dit
et qui fait à partir de là on a fait un
certain nombre de propositions
on n'a pas présenté de collier aux
présidentielles on l'a amené la moitié
des mères pour soutenir la candidature
de jean-luc mélenchon
on a fait des propositions de
répartition équitable sur les
constructions non pas dans un espèce de
tripoux ya simplement pour que toute la
gauche dans sa diversité soient
représentés
c'est pas que france a soumises et le
parti communiste c'est aussi des
syndicalistes c'est aussi des membres
des milieux associatifs et y compris par
rapport à ça sur la première
circonscription nous avons une
particularité d'avoir une députée que
vous avez interrogé juste avant qu'ils
aient frondeuse et qui est très proche
de nous il est donc on a dit aux se
rapproche sur un certain nombre de
points et pour vincent appareil est
impossible sur la deuxième circuit en
tout cas nous on a fait la démonstration
de ce chevreuil que sur la première
scène constitution nous sommes allés au
bout de la démarche
nous n'avons pas présenté de candidat je
l'avais annoncé
nous l'avons fait et donc à partir de là
parce que on veut gagner à députés parce
qu'on veut avoir des députés demain
assure à certains de choses je
soutiendrai sur cette première session
barbara romagnan pour qu'elle aille le
plus loin possible au moins c'est clair
une question supplémentaire christophe
lime votre candidature est-elle celle
d'une primaires pour les municipales de
2001 je m'explique vous êtes quatre élus
municipaux sur ce plateau à gauche pour
succéder à jean luc mélenchon il ya deux
noms qui reviennent régulièrement celui
d'eric à l'oser et celui de christophe
lima question est donc simple
êtes vous déjà en campagne municipale je
ne suis pas capable municipal et pour
être en campagne municipale je ne
changerai pas de parti politique pour
avoir plus de chance pour pouvoir y
arriver j'ai une fidélité je suis
reconnue par rapport à ces engagements
la par rapport à mon travail et donc si
un jour je venais représentés au niveau
de l'élection municipale
je me présenterais avec mon étiquette
avec des forces rassemblées autour de
moi pour pouvoir peser sur un certain
nombre de programmes
mais n'ayez pas peur tous les matins je
ne me lève pas pour en horaires dans la
glace pour savoir
je veux être élu je me regarde dans la
glace tous les matins pour savoir si la
veille
j'ai été fidèle à mes engagements merci
david on va accueillir bernard bayot de
l'est républicain qui vous écoute depuis
le début de ce débat et bernard qui
souhaite vous interroger sur des
questions très précises concernant la
fiscalité locale et l'avenir de nos
collectivités
oui bonjour à vous donc ce sont des
questions qu'un peu technique mais
finalement très très proche de nous et
ma première question porte sur la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation que
une mesure très très médiatique et ma
question est la suivante et je m'adresse
à vous aussi à louvain est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils auraient pas mieux valu
jouer sur les taux et les basses pardon
qui date de 1970 s comprend pas un
risque a remporté à rembourser à leur
prêt des collectivités vertueuse et les
autres noms vertueuse vous savez que
cette réforme est impossible ça fait des
décennies qu'on veut réformer les bases
et on n'y arrive pas pourquoi parce que
havelock constante
effectivement ça peut être bénéfique
pour un certain nombre de ménages aux
revenus modestes puissent comprend les
revenus et non plus la valeur de
l'habitation mais les revenus et ça a
conduit à l'augmentation pour les autres
les autres ménages y compris pour les
personnes de la classe moyenne et donc
on n'arrive pas à faire cette réforme
c'est l'impasse dont classe a au moins
le mérite extrêmement clair c'est une
mesure classes moyennes pourquoi c'est
une mesure classe moyenne parce que les
20% des personnes les plus aisées
continueront à la payer et parce que les
personnes les plus modestes la paye pape
mais vous c'est du midi six salles vous
j'irais là j'ai un certain de
difficultés c'est ça que vous voulez
sans doute indiquer effectivement ce
avec dans la loi il ya un principe qui
est la compensation à l'euro l'euro
c'est que les recettes pour les
collectivités locales sera compensée
totalement
maintenant moi je travaillerai 1 pour
que y ait une
un ajustement annuel par rapport à
l'inflation ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
c'est à dire si vous êtes remboursé 100
malades est elle plus de ces sandales et
une puce 3g sans alors qu'elle
l'inflation donc il faut un dispositif
pour qui un ajustement par rapport à
l'inflation et d'autre part que les
nouvelles constructions ou les nouvelles
taxes nouvelles bases soient prises en
compte dans la compensation aux
collectivités locales va donc c'est une
c'est une mesure de pouvoir d'achat pour
les classes moyennes qui simplifie cette
réforme qu'on n'arrive jamais à faire
finalement de la taxe je vais être plus
précis dans la question et je me tourne
christophe lime par exemple à besançon
la taxe d'habitation ses 1200 13 euros
par habitant à dijon et 829 euros
on va avoir une perte de 24 millions
d'euros à peu près est ce qu'on prend
pas un risque sur la durée en remettant
j'irai les plis de pouvoir à bercy sur
le remboursement de la taxe d'habitation
c'est la dernière étape de la
suppression des communes c'est ça qu'il
faut dire le dernier quinquennat à
engager la fin des communes avec des
transferts d étranglement financier la
fin d assistance de l'état est donc
aujourd'hui la dernière possibilité que
peuvent avoir les communes c'est de
lever l'impôt donc la stratégie sur
cette exonération c'est d'amener à la
suppression de la commune je suis
attaché à la commune
tout ce qui ira pour la lire à la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
structures au niveau communal j'y serais
opposé sur les aspects financiers au
niveau des communes il y a deux réformes
à faire par rapport à ça c'est le
relèvement des exonérations qui
permettent de payer moins pour un
certain nombre de familles tout
particulièrement les familles moyennes
avec une partie de la population ne
payent pas la taxe d'habitation c'est
l'état qui rembourse donc je demande le
relèvement par rapport à ça et sur le
financement au niveau de communes
je demande la mise en place d'une taxe
sur les actifs financiers des banques
pour pouvoir payer le l'ensemble des
dépenses au niveau des collectivités
pourquoi ça parce qu'on sait que les
collectivités quand elles investissent
un euro ça ramène trois heureux à
l'inter d'une économie au niveau local
donc cet investissement là au lieu de
faire du cic dont on sait que ça n'a
rien apporté au titre du chômage
on investit avec nos collectivités on
répond aux besoins de l'ensemble de la
population et on dynamise l'ensemble de
nos entreprises qui sont au niveau local
c'est ça qui est intéressant
julien a car vous aviez demandé à parler
oui tout à fait il est important de
préciser aussi que le gouvernement
monsieur macron a précisé que dans cette
réforme de la taxe habitation
elles seraient compensées a
effectivement par rapport aux communales
et à l'épaule
les communes sont récompensés alors la
question de savoir comment elles vont
être compensés et il est prévu dans le
programme de monsieur macron d'augmenter
la csg c'est à dire que c'est une taxe
tout à fait injuste qui touchent
absolument tout le monde des petits
retraités les salariés précaires les
demandeurs d'emploi et nous nous y
sommes farouchement opposés à cette
augmentation de la csg qui est
d'ailleurs je le rappelle a déjà
augmenté dans le précédent mandat
monsieur fagots taxe d'habitation pas
taxe d'habitation alors je pense que
c'est un gros risque que la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation
puisque c'est une atteinte aux libertés
locales comme a pu le dire christophe
lime et très justement et j'ai souscrit
à ces propos c'est qu'on a vécu un
matraquage fiscal sans précédent durant
ce quinquennat
nos collectivités locales notre ruralité
a été aussi attaqué par rapport à cela
si vous prenez par exemple la commune de
tizi est une commune de la 2e
circonscription c'est moins 65 mille
euros sur la dotation globale de
fonctionnement l'année dernière et moins
100000 l'année précédente
si vous leur supprimer la taxe
d'habitation ou va-t-elle aller chercher
les recettes alors quand l'état nous
parle de compensation on sait que dans
la loi de finances s'est inscrit mais
c'est inscrit aussi de façon dégressive
donc je pense que c'est une vraie
difficulté vous connaissez le problème
en tant qu'élu départementale notamment
effectivement quand vous savez qu'au
niveau du département sur ces quatre
dernières années
c'est moins 60 75 millions d'euros de
dotation globale de fonctionnement donc
je pense que là on va supprimer une
nouvelle partie des recettes de nos
collectivités locales de notre ruralité
notamment qui a été beaucoup impacter
durant ce quinquennat
et qu'est ce qui va rester à nos
communes les forêts le foncier je pense
pas que ce soit la bonne mesure de lever
la taxe d'habitation
mademoiselle arnould votre position par
rapport à la taxe d'habitation or madame
donc déjà le premier point c'est que
c'est c'est quand on voit depuis
plusieurs années qu'il ya tout un
ensemble de mesures à chaque fois on
réinvente une nouvelle mesure c'est là
cette fois c'est la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation pour les foyers
fiscaux les plus en difficulté mais on
voit qu'il ya aucune
depuis plusieurs années il ya aucune
vraie politique fiscale d'importance en
france qui remettent vraiment à base à
plat les bases du système et nous ce
qu'on propose c'est une révolution
fiscale avec quelques principes simples
qui s'applique tout à la fois au niveau
national et au niveau local on veut une
véritable progressivité de l'impôt et la
taxe d'habitation rentre dans ce cadre
de révolution fiscale avec une véritable
progressivité
après nous sur les mains on est
également au niveau du des territoires
il faut revenir un aménagement du
territoire qu'ils soient organisées
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on a une
disparition des communes disparition des
départements et qu'on a des
intercommunalités qui développe des
grandes régions qui n'ont aucun sens ça
a quel sens la grande pour créer la
grande région bourgogne franche comté
quand vous avez le nord de l'yonne qui
est complètement pris dans l'airé
urbaine parisienne et vous avez le sud
avec le jura saint claude donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que là il faut vraiment
rebattre complètement les quatre cartes
et c'est pad avec des réformes des
effets d'annoncé comme ça sur la taxe
d'habitation qu'on va y arriver
donc nous le principe est simple c'est
la progressivité de l'impôt et d'autre
part quand j'entends emmanuel macron on
parlait de compensation enfin ça le même
qui propose des baisses massives de
dotations de l'état
faut savoir qu'à besançon actuellement
le délai pour avoir une carte d'identité
ces sept mois pour avoir un passeport
ses sept mois donc là il ya une vraie
n'y a absolument aucune cohérence dans
ce qui est proposé par emmanuel macron
notre programme l'admira commun une
véritable cohérence et nous allons
défendre à l'assemblée nationale alors
justement vous amener à la question
suivante qui concerne la réforme
territoriale alors besançon peut accéder
grâce notamment à un abonnement de
monsieur alauzet au statut de communauté
urbaine
alors selon vous est ce que il faut que
besançon a eu au plus vite vers le
statut de communauté urbaine dans le
cadre de la compétition avec les autres
collectivités ou parce que au contraire
il faut pas le faire je me tourne vers
vous mais si a qu'à écouter
là dessus nous avons toujours été très
claire au moment du débat sur la loi
nôtre nous sommes intervenus à la ville
de besançon et à l'agglomération pour
dénoncer les ravages de cette loi qui
n'est finalement qu'une succession de
décisions de l'union européenne qui
impose à terme de remplacer les communes
les départements et la nation par un
nouveau triptyque l'intercommunalité d
euros méga région est effectivement
l'union européenne nous y sommes
absolument opposés
nous pensons nous que les échelons de
proximité que sont les communes et les
départements permettent de ne pas
éloigner les centres de décision vous
avez tout à fait raison de dire que
cette région bourgogne franche comté à
laquelle je siège n'a absolument
on n'a absolument rien à voir quand on
est à belfort à sens voilà les gens ne
s'identifie pas à ces échelons et on
manque de proximité des centres de
décision ludovic fagots faut-il revoir
le découpage actuel le millefeuille
actuelle faut-il retouché à cette
répartition qui a déjà été pas mal
chamboulé ces dernières années ce n'est
pas le département l'échelon de trop je
ne pense pas que département soit un
échelon trop bien au contraire à
l'échelon de proximité c'est la commune
avec le maire c'est le conseiller
départemental puisque on est vraiment en
proximité avec avec les habitants
maintenant à la question de chevreuils
sur le fait de revoir ce découpage
administratif de circonscription de
canton je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
priorité en ce moment la priorité quand
même bien d'ailleurs la priorité c'est
l'emploi la priorité c'est la sécurité
et je pense
ce que plutôt que de repartir en tout
cas dans une inertie qui n'amènera rien
en tout cas aux citoyens soyons très
pragmatique
prenons les choses dans l'ordre et
agissons sur ce qui doit être
prioritaire comme j'ai pu vous le dire à
l'instant merci bernard n'en a plus le
temps berne et david mal va revenir
david qui vous a écouté qui souhaitent
approfondir quelques quelques points
david vous avez trois minutes avant la
conclusion des candidats allez c'est
parti vous êtes le candidat de la
majorité présidentielle eric alauzet ce
que c'est ce que vous nous avez dit vous
soutiendrez donc le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron est-ce que vous voterez
une loi puisque on a beaucoup parlé de
découpage territorial
une loi qui supprimerait un département
pour mettre en avant la métropole
l'agglomération de besançon
je pense que les deux évolutions qui
peuvent se produire sur ce mandat sont
les éventuels comme une nouvelle terre
des fusions de communes
ça ce sera largement encouragé ce que ça
le sera réglementairement ou par des
incitations financières c'est trop tôt
pour le dire
et c'est effectivement la possibilité
sur la base du volontariat des
départements où il ya une grosse
agglomération c'est le cas de lyon qui
est déjà en route sur sept dans cette
direction donc la ville métropole peut
encaisser les compétences sociales du
département puisque c'est de ça dont il
s'agit puisque 50% le budget des
départements c'est l'action sociale donc
dans ces grandes métropoles
effectivement il pourra y avoir cette
évolution pas dans les autres dépouilles
à la disparition des départements là où
ça s'impose là où il ya des grosses
agglomérations
julien car cette vision du candidat de
la majorité présidentielle qui dit oui
on peut supprimer les départements où il
faut revoir l'organisation territoriale
mais c'est scandaleux moi quand
j'entends un écologiste nous dire qu'il
faut plus de métropole si vous voulez je
suis un peu de quoi tomber par terre
nous nous sommes tout à fait opposés à
la réforme de la loi note nous
souhaitons revenir en arrière supprimer
les régions qui sont des gouffres
financiers on dépense énormément
d'argent pour final très peu de services
aux citoyens et redit encore c'est
surtout re dispatcher les compétences
entre celles qui relèvent du domaine de
la nation de l'état et celles qui
relèvent du domaine local via les
départements qui sont des échoppes
proximité mais vous du coup vous voulez
tout revoir oui tout à fait c'était un
programme présidentiel de marine le pen
au risque de choquer de on s'habitue à
peine la grande région qu'il faudra
justement je pense justement je pense
que on n'y est pas du tout habitués
contrairement à ce que vous avez l'air
de sous-entendre chercheurs français je
suis amène à peine justement je pense
qu'il faut profiter qu'on soit au tout
début pour revenir en arrière avant que
ce soit trop tard alors on est parti sur
un débat sur la fiscalité locale
on a abouti à une discussion sur le
millefeuille sur les communes sur vous
avez même eu cette formule christophe
lime
c'est la dernière étape de la fin des
communes
c'est ça le projet de manuel malchance
georges jean ce j'en suis convaincu
qu'il faut dit eric alauzet finale face
aux micros installés sur le coeur ça a
été engagée sur le dernier ça a été
engagée sur le dernier quinquennat une
peur aux gens vraiment forte
saeed mis en application on nous créer
des structures qu'il correspond
absolument pas à la vie j'ai prendre la
communauté de communes qui démarre de
arc-et-senans qui va jusqu'à avancer
on nous dit que c'est un bassin de vie
on nous dit que le bassin de vie
bourgogne franche comté entre le début
de la nièvre le bourgogne est un bassin
de vie donc ça veut dire y compris sur
ce thème là je rappelle que certains ont
soutenu la fin de la capitale régionale
sur besançon c'est scandaleux parce que
savané aucune économie et ça va amener
un appauvrissement et un éloignement
d'un certain nombre de direction au
niveau de besançon et on va en payer les
pots cassés dans un certain endroit je
serai très attentif à deux domaines sur
la capitale régionale très vite c'est
l'université et l'hôpital qui sont d
excellence qui va falloir garder
attention c'est des points de fragilité
dans le cadre de la nouvelle conception
niveau la région merci on arrive
quasiment au terme de cette émission je
vais vous demander à chacun 40 secondes
de conclusion on commence avec vous
claire arnoux a donc du coup
alors moi je pensais encore répondre sur
le sur la question donc je vais
reprendre sur un terme qu'un de vos
collègues et employés
il a dit la compétitivité entre les
territoires et moi je voudrais dire que
justement notre programme celle inverse
de ça on n'a pas être en compétition
permanente et besançon n'est pas en
compétition avec dijon donc on est pour
une société qui soit celle du partage
qui soit celle d'un aménagement du
territoire cohérent sur l'ensemble du
territoire et nous ce qu'on propose
c'est la planification écologique
il ya quelque chose dont j'aurais voulu
parler aujourd'hui donc je le place et
maintenant c'est alstom à ornans
parce que c'est sur la circonscription
et alstom ça fait partie des des
dossiers phares de ces présidentielles
donc ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que
nous on est pour un protectionnisme
solidaires pour défendre ses fleurons
industriels là qui doivent nous
permettre de faire la transition
énergétique qui doivent permettre de
développer le réseau ferré et eric
alauzet ici présents soutient le
président emmanuel macron kick ass
cesser ses fleurons industriels l'a donc
une politique écologique une politique
sociale un partage des richesses et du
temps de travail avec l'avenir en commun
christain film votre conclusion s'il
vous plaît moi je moi je rame je ramène
sur l'unité du rassemblement
on a une gauche qui est diverse ceux qui
croient qu'ils vont tout cela rassembler
derrière anneaux se trompe on a des
points de rassemblement on a des points
de différence qui nous font notre
richesse
il faut qu'on arrive à être unis pour
pouvoir se batailler par rapport à ça à
se rassembler par rapport à ça pourquoi
parce que nous sommes à la veille de la
mise en place d'une politique très
libérale soutenue par macro ou une
politique encore plus libérale menée par
la droite où le front national sur
lequel on n'a pas obligatoirement des
grandes valeurs communes donc pour moi
je serai le candidat de résistance par
rapport à toutes ces politiques là
j'étais un candidat de résistance par
rapport à la politique hollande valls et
mon fils conducteurs mon fils rouges
chassera l'humain d'abord et tout ce qui
doit préserver la planète
merci christophe lime julien car votre
conclusion bien je pense que cette
élection a eu au moins deux
présidentielles a eu au moins le mérite
de clarifier les choses et on assiste à
une recomposition de la vie politique
est totale celle que nous annoncions
depuis plusieurs années un clivage entre
les mondialistes ceux qui ne croient
plus en la france qui n'aime plus la
france et puis les patriotes ceux qui
croient encore que notre nation est
grande que nous avons un avenir
important à bâtir ensemble et je pense
qu'effectivement avec cette majorité que
nous pouvons avoir autour de marine le
pen
nous nous nous réussirons à nous opposer
vivement aux politiques de monsieur
mâcon qui sont dévastatrices
merci julien a car ludovic fagots votre
conclusion je pense que la france est un
tournant décisif et notre deuxième
circonscription est également à un
tournant décisif après il est légitime
que les personnes aient des doutes mais
en tout cas moi je refuse ce fatalisme
et je pense qu'il faut en finir avec
cette ambiguïté et puis ces candidats
qui sont un petit peu attrape tout donc
c'est pour ça que moi je pense incarner
aussi cette ce renouvellement cette
nouvelle génération avec des agissements
en clarté et sans ambiguïté avec des
valeurs du travail la famille qu'il faut
qu'il faut vraiment soutenir et en tout
cas moi je veux près là c'est la culture
du résultat en tout cas auxerre au coeur
de mon action et je défendrai l'identité
bien sûr que notre identité française
merci ludovic fagots eric alauzet mon
obsession c'est toujours d'essayer de
rapprocher les uns et les autres je m'y
emploie depuis des années et je vais
continuer à le faire sous la bannière
qu'à celle de l'écologie et de
l'humanisme qui a ma marque depuis
depuis tout le temps
c'est pour ça que je pense que celui qui
aujourd'hui donne ce signal là à la fois
d'une bouffée d'air frais et du
rassemblement
c'est le président la république c'est
pour ça que je m'inscris dans cette
majorité présidentielle avec à la fois
une exigence de loyauté parce qu'il faut
avancer et qu'on voit que toutes ces
oppositions qui sont exprimées ici en
permanence on est contre tout frêne le
pays et avec aussi en étant un homme
libre et surtout écologistes et après
lens d'emmanuel macron va être un appui
pour moi extraordinaire pour faire
avancer notre pays dans ce sens merci à
tous les cinq je rappelle que c'est sont
aussi candidats sur cette
circonscription jean claude chaumette
pour debout la france josé da cruz
candidats divers nadine de maillots
partie animalistes fabrice delcambre
lutte ouvrière alain françois divers et
christine latournerie upr merci à tous
ce débat est à revoir
sur internet je vous donne d'ailleurs
rendez vous dès 15h sur nos sites
internet pour deux débats la première de
haute saône vesoul gray est la deuxième
du genre à champagnole saint-claude
profitez bien de votre après midi et a
tout de suite la politique continue sur
france 3
[Musique]